okay now we're going to work on our
first op-amp circuit here's what the
circuit is going to look like watch
where I put the plus sign is on the top
on this one and we're going to have a
voltage source over here this will be
plus or minus VN that's our input signal
and over on the output will have V out
and it's hooked up this way
there's a resistor another resistor to
ground and this goes back to the
inverting input and we're going to look
at this circuit and see what it does
now we know that connected up here the
power supplies hooked up to these points
here and the ground symbol is zero volts
and we want we want to analyze this
circuit and what do we know about this
we know that V out equals some gain will
write the gain right there a big big
number times V minus sorry v+ minus v-
and let's label that v plus is this
point right here and V minus is this
point right here and we also know that
the currents let's call them I plus and
I minus equals zero and that's the
currents going in here this is I minus
here and that's I plus and we know those
are both zero so now what I want to do
is describe what's going on inside this
triangle symbol in more detail by
building a circuit model alright and the
circuit model for an amplifier looks
like this we have V minus here V Plus
here so this is V in and over on this
side we haven't here's a new symbol that
you haven't seen before it's usually
drawn as a diamond shape and this is a
voltage source
but is this it's a special kind of
voltage source it's called a voltage
dependent voltage source
and it's the same as a regular ideal
voltage source except for one thing it
says that the V in this case V out
equals gain times V plus minus V minus
so the voltage here depends on the
voltage somewhere else and that's what
makes it a voltage dependent that's what
that means
so we've just taken our gain expression
here and drawn a circuit diagram that
represents our voltage expression for
our circuit now specifically over here
we draw on an open circuit on v+ + v -
so we know that those currents are zero
so this model this this circuit sketch
represents our two properties of our of
our op-amp so I'm going to take a second
here and I'm going to draw our the rest
of our circuit surrounding this model
but I need a little bit more space so
let's put in the rest of our circuit
here we had our voltage source connected
to V Plus and that's V in and over here
we had V out let's check VI was
connected to two resistors and the
bottom is connected to ground and this
was connected there so what our goal is
right now we want to find V out as a
function of V n that's what we're
shooting for so let's see if we can do
that let's give our resistor some names
let's call this r1 and r2 our favorite
names always and now everything is
labeled oh and we can label this point
here and this point we can call V - V -
so that's our two unknowns our unknowns
are V naught V out and V minus so let's
see if we can find them so what I'm
going to do is just start writing some
expressions for things that I know are
true for example I know that I know that
V out equals a times V Plus - V - all
right that's that's what that's what
this op-amp is telling us is true now
what else do I know let's look at this
resistor chain here this resistor chain
actually looks a lot like a voltage
divider and it's actually a very good
voltage divider remember we said this
current here what is this current here
it's zero I can use the voltage divider
expression that I know in that case I
know that V - this is the voltage
divider equation equals V out times what
times the bottom resistor remember this
r2 over r1 plus r2 so the voltage
divider expression says that when you
have a stack of resistors like this with
a voltage on the top and ground on the
bottom this is the expression for the
voltage at the mid point okay so what
I'm going to do next is I'm going to
take this expression and stuff it right
in there let's do that see if we get
enough room okay let's go over here now
I can say that V out equals a times V
plus minus V out times r2 over r1 plus
r2
right so far so good let's keep going
let's keep working on this V naught
equals a times V plus minus a V naught
r2 over r1 plus r2
all right so now I'm going to gather all
the V naught terms over on the left hand
side let's try that so that gives me V
naught plus a V naught times r2 over r1
plus r2 and that equals a times V plus
and actually I can change that now V
plus is what V Plus is V in okay let's
keep going I can factor out the V naught
V naught is 1 plus a r2 over r1 plus r2
and that equals AV in all right so we're
getting close and our original goal we
want to find V out in terms of V in so
I'm going to take this whole expression
here and divide it over to the other
side so then I have just V naught on
this side and V in on the other side
this makes more room I can do that I can
say V naught equals a V n divided by
this big ol expression 1 plus a r2 over
r1 plus r2 all right so that's our
answer that's the answer that's V out
equals some fun
action of V in now I want to make it a
really important observation here we're
going to this is going to be a real cool
simplification okay so this is the point
where op-amp Theory gets really cool
watch what happens here we know that a
is a giant number a is something like 10
to the fifth or 10 to the sixth and it's
whatever we have here if our resistors
are sort of normal sized resistors we
know that a giant number times a normal
number is still going to be a very big
number compared to one so this one is
almost insignificant in this expression
down here so what I'm going to do bear
with me I'm going to cross it out I'm
going to say now I don't need that
anymore
so if this if this number here if a is a
million 10 to the sixth and this
expression here is something like 1/2
then this total thing is one half of 10
to the 6 or 1/2 a million and that's
huge compared to 1 so I can pretty
safely ignore the 1 it's very very small
now when I do that well look what
happens next
now I have a top and bottom in the
expression and I can cancel that too so
the a goes away now this is pretty
astonishing we have this amplifier
circuit and all of a sudden I have an
expression here where a doesn't appear
the gain does not appear and what does
this turn into this is called V naught
equals V n times what times r1 plus r2
divided by r2 so our amplifier our
feedback circuit came down to V out is V
n multiplied by the ratio of the
resistors that we added to the circuit
this is one of the really cool
properties of using op amps in circuits
really high gain amplifiers what we've
done is we could chosen the gain of our
circuit based on the components that we
pick to add to the amplifier it's not
determined by the gain of the amplifier
as long as the amplifier gain is really
really big and for op amps it's that's a
good assumption it is really big so this
expression came out with a positive sign
right
all the ours or positive values so this
is referred to as a non-inverting op-amp
circuit amplifier so just to do a quick
example if r1 and r2 are the same then
we end up with an expression that looks
like this V out equals R 1 plus R 2 R
plus R over R is equal to 2 so the gain
is 2 times V n so just to do a quick
sketch just to remind ourselves what
this looks like this was V n and we had
what out here we had a resistor and a
resistor to ground and this is V out so
this is the configuration of a
non-inverting amplifier built with an
op-amp the two resistors in this voltage
divider string connected to the negative
input so that's what a non-inverting
op-amp circuit looks like and it's going
to be one of the familiar patterns that
you'll see over and over again as you
read schematics and you design your own
circuits